cyber security is one of the most
popular career options in IT industry
but landing a job in cyber security it's
not that easy you need to build a very
strong resume with very strong points
including education degree projects and
certifications and certifications are
among the most important criteria for
any HR or a manager to select the
rightful candidate for his most
prestigious cyber security job in big
companies that will show the right
skills and expertise that you have in
this field so in this video I'm going to
talk about top five cyber security
certifications and my picks in order for
you to land a job in cyber security and
kick start your career in cyber security
so let's get started we keep hearing
this fact from many people in it that
cyber security is biggest market right
now and it's only gonna boom but how
many people are getting supplied many
people are getting supplied but there is
an imbalance between the supply and
demand only because the supply that we
are getting is not rightfully skilled we
get a lot of candidates but are they
actually skilled toward the industry one
according to a trusted survey there will
be million job opportunities and
openings by 2023 in India itself but if
you want to land a job and a good job
you need to be skilled to the core and
yeah I know you might have this question
that people ask me very often for
learning why do certifications why not
degrees why not colleges so the fact is
that College learning is not many times
not very often at par with what industry
demands there is a huge gap you may not
even be able to learn cyber security in
your college studies that's the truth
but in order to be good in this field
you need to be adaptive you need to
adapt at a pace that's not very often
kept up in college degree programs
syllabus don't very often change in this
degree programs while I do recommend
people to get at least one bachelor's
degree in CS or it but certifications
are the best way to boost your resume
and skills at the same time because they
take very less time they just focus on
one important Niche and go very deep
into it it and they generally don't cost
you as much as a degree while degree can
cost you in lakhs maybe 10 or more but a
certification will not cost you more
than a lakh or two and in a degree
you're taught many more things that you
don't even need in your career that you
want to pursue but a certification will
give you a path to follow in your future
so here are my picks for the top five
certifications in cyber security that
will give you a good position in top
company and your dream job so I'll try
to list them in order of the experience
level so the very first certifications
that you will and you should do is ceh
certified ethical hacker this is the
most basic course that you can do that
will build the very fundamentals of you
understanding how attacks work how to
find issues in hacking a system this is
the bare minimum that everyone should do
in order to get started to get to know
what this field looks like so people new
into this field and just want to start
their career as a fresher I think this
is one of the best certifications to do
I know many people don't count it as
worth because it's lacking very Hands-On
training on real world scenarios but at
the end of the day it's a building block
and it gives you a mark of a certified
hacker and still HRS and India look for
this badge at the bare minimum in many
cases so you can be hard as a pentester
or a security analyst and then break the
barrier of experience once and for all
and while you work you can focus on your
skill set and build and do more
certifications in the future and just
keep growing I know it's difficult to
manage skill development when you work
full time even I face the same
especially when you are doing it on your
own in self-learning well well I know a
program that can make you a certified
ethical hacker while you study and guide
you on your learning I'm talking about
simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security that is backed by top
expert study programs and faculty from
mid schwasman College of computing and
even EC Council the program is an online
boot camp that runs for six months where
you will learn from industry experts how
to design build and Implement secure
systems at scale in large scale
organizations the course covers 20 of
the most popular and important security
domains and how to apply best practices
in all of them and it is also aligned
with CompTIA Security Plus and will
teach all the standards covered there it
will also teach you how to develop a
hacker mindset identify and manage
threats and also the overall security
posture of large-scale organizations at
the end of The Learning you will get a
Capstone project where you will apply
your industry skills and you will get a
chance to Showcase your expertise to
Future employers you will also get
access to easy council's learning kit
and ceh V12 ilabs access for six months
along with an exam voucher which will
make you a certified ethical hacker
while you study and you will also get a
certificate from MIT schwarzman College
of computing that is really valuable in
your resume so to be eligible for this
program you should have a bachelor's
degree with 50 percent or more of grades
and you need not have any programming
experience or any prior work experience
so the application for this program is
really very simple just go to the link
in the description click on the link
review all the program details click on
apply Now button on the page fill all
the required details asked from you and
just submit and wait for the reward back
and I know there are not many good
programs out there that can offer you so
much at the same time so don't think
just go for it the second third is
CompTIA Security Plus I know ceh is very
popular in India but if you talk about
all around the world CompTIA has done
really good job in establishing a
foothold in this industry this is also a
basic certification made for beginners
which will teach you how to secure
network systems and applications it's
more on the security side rather than
the offensive side and it's greatly
aligned to Modern Enterprise environment
and in-demand topics that ceh in some
way fails to cover including Cloud
mobile and iot it also covers components
risk and compliance but yeah many people
will think that we still require
practical certifications but this is
also a theoretical certification that
will have 90 Performance Based questions
that are not straightforward that will
check your concept overall what you have
learned but still is theoretical but if
you want to get a job in foreign in us
or in UK or anywhere around the world
it's one of the most recognized
certifications out there you can be
hired as a security engineer Cloud
engineer ID auditor with a very
competitive package the third one is G
SEC or giac certified security engineer
those who are already working in
Cooperative world may already know that
Sans is one of the top and one of the
best trainers in the world out there and
I've personally done gpen and I know
that the knowledge that you get there is
nowhere else the top experts from each
field come out and teach and of course
that comes with a cost gsec is one of
the best selling certifications giac has
to offer it will teach you active
defense technique network security Cloud
security incident response for n6 so it
is one of the best certifications for
blue teaming and the salary hike here is
real I can tell you from my personal
experience if your base is low you can
easily get a 50 hike if your base is
high then you can easily get 30 40 high
but the catch here is I think not many
individuals can afford this because the
cost is really very high it can even go
to seven to eight lakhs for a single
training and certification so you can
only do that if your employer sponsors
you so if your employer has a good bank
balance and is good enough you will want
to do Sans training again and again and
again fourth one is seesaw or certified
information security auditor risk and
compliance are a very crucial aspect of
cyber security in today's world
especially if you are working in an
organization that deals with sensitive
customer data like Health finance and
government agencies so esaka comes up
with this credential that will focus on
how to assess security vulnerabilities
how to report and identify risk and
manage compliance according to various
standards based on the customer data in
the Department Industry they are in you
must have heard about some data
standards like PCI DSS ISO or HIPAA they
all come around this and this is one of
the best certifications that you can do
for a governance risk and compliance job
or a GRC or an auditor risk manager or a
cyber audit manager and the truth is
cyber Auditors are more respected than
pen testers because they are more wise
in decision making and they have a good
grip and understanding of how to assess
business risk but the certification
requires some prior experience in IIT
Assurance so if you want to switch into
auditing then you can definitely take
this the fifth one is cissp or sisp or
certified information system security
professional and this is no doubt one of
the best or maybe the best the most
prestigious certification in all of
infosec earning which you will be able
to run complex security program arms and
manage them just what csos and managers
and directors do you will be capable of
running a complete cyber security
program right from design analysis
implementation and managing a complete
info departments that just not includes
technical expertise but also management
expertise because that's what you learn
here and I can tell you the salaries
here are way more than what we desire
seriously it is meant for experienced
professionals with at least five years
of professional work experience in
infosec and have a bachelor's degree but
here if I talk about salaries they can
easily go to 50 LPA and even Beyond 50 L
for a CSO and you can even work as a
security consultant for World Stop
organizations with a package only above
competition so these are my top picks
for cyber security certifications in
2023 that you can do in order to get
started in a cyber security career or
even get eventually good and experience
then switch over to different fields if
you are experienced so I hope you like
this video and you got something able to
learn from this and don't forget to
enroll into simply learns postgraduate
program in cyber security that will give
you industry guidance skills and also
certifications at the same time and do
share this video with somebody that you
feel might be benefited from this just
like you did so that's all in this video
from my side I hope to see you again
till then keep learning and goodbye